шановний грузите ще зубищі
прийняла але ще один дебільний закон
про дір службу вдалося на нашому колезі
руслан князевич у бейкер ще там ви
проводьте і я б хотів щоб руслан
князевич процес раз перед диякони
шеннон і коли я galaxy zoom вузли віз
едуардович та
такого нахабного та цинічного обожнення
прописати всі закони відчуває супер
служби та
через крим кабінету міністрів
центральних упустив падаючої води заважають
адміністрація шини більша за те, що
перехідних положеннях база кінчику ці
не botas тусується там зовсім менше вони
врятували федеральна служба з відмінно
всіх державна служба вс і потім законом
завтра буде видно на подібних
ґрунтувати б жадібних гарантій
вид vertu кількі я і найтлі прогадаю
щоб лукава між валявся для таких
промов
а особисто прийшли далі ми бачимо внизу ви
просто я-то хоч одна трохи але при до
тому ж вибачається і викликати у
противники скільки заряду комп'ютери
якщо liquid про виведення то ви природно
буду секретаріатом та міністерств
противником знайти процесу коли рядах
місцях адміністрації
хотіла переписати цю нову закон про
кабінет міністрів та кен перекрито
кабінет міністрів гарту реально
вормікс прозорих інструкцій у залі
фішок шкода прем'єр-міністра скакки
пролунало що всі засідання вдумайтесь
мало провід тут у режимі відео як
паротита не вимагала їхній брат наші дні
як на межі страх достатньо було
порожні монітори до кабінету та
прем'єр-міністра і побачив лісу про ти
похитника біт місію рішення хотіла
примати шляхів досвід і вільні до восьмого
тут починається проекту рішення та галочки
в казан профі для того щоб брата і
прибирання публічного спадкоємцями дагестану
шакала я закривалася і активно барроу
частина гри таку програмісту сенсу
розмішую збувається шляхи потім особистому
режимі примати відблиски в вибачаєшся не
купиш так лояльний
вирву сильних провести ворожий закрито
пічників ворону я не думав що він
прем'єр-міністр країни і занудьгувала все
роботі закритися засідання не пускаєш
вигадав помилився вершина автобусики поршик
роду аудіокурс більше новачкові я народу
дослухала з наших романтика 8 руслан
якби підтвердження замерцяв би
ти хоча б маленьку прямому ефірі
здобули спину цілі для свого сайту ось
така історія ось такі закони тут прямо
ми бором та родинами можемо nudist вона
просто
робом ось ще можемо, а наша фракція
європейської солідарні пройти
розум пари можемо рожна dapper міг дякую